[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
frança 24 hoy ya es martes 2 de agosto
iniciamos ya en forma este verano bueno
un poco tal que tanto del anual noreste
este diferente al de el de barcelona en
duda
abrimos revista de prensa repasando el
perfil de ayman al-zawahiri el día de
al-qaeda vinculado rosa con los
atentados del 11 de septiembre del año
2001 en la ciudad de nueva york las
torres gemelas recordemos porque yo
baiden acabo de anunciar de que el
ejército estadounidense lo mató este fin
de semana con un ataque del drone vamos
a ver entonces cómo lo cuenta al yazira
hace un perfil de esta persona no
efectivamente hay una cosa que resalta
al yazira tanto como los otros medios de
comunicación es que precisamente este
ataque de drone tuvo lugar en kabul
donde él residía lo que plantea ciertas
preguntas así como acusaciones cruzadas
entre el gobierno talibán entre
afganistán y eeuu respecto al
incumplimiento de los acuerdos de doha
que son los acuerdos recordemos que
permitieron en los que se enmarcó la
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses
de afganistán
por un lado los talibán dicen que esta
es una violación de su soberanía un
ataque estadounidense en su territorio
mientras que eeuu reprocha a los
talibanes que no les alertaron de que
había una terroristas de los más
buscados sino el más buscado por eeuu
pues en su territorio recordemos 25
millones de dólares andaba
eeuu por información que guiara hasta al
zawahiri en todo caso vamos a ver cómo
termina esta cuestión más diplomática
por decirlo de algún modo pero en todo
caso el perfil que hace al yazira
repasa un poco estos 71 años de vida que
tenía al zawahiri cuando lo mató a eeuu
este fin de semana en todo caso era
oftalmólogo y por ello tenía el
seudónimo de de doctor nació en el cairo
en egipto en
1951 y se le atribuye un poco la
estrategia y toda la ideología detrás de
la creación de la red global terrorista
de al-qaeda como tal como bien decía
se supone que estuvo detrás de los
atentados contra las torres gemelas de
eeuu del 11 de septiembre de 2001 pero
también contra las embajadas de kenia y
tanzania en 1998 que fue allí digamos
cuando saltó a la escena internacional y
ahí cuando eeuu empezó a buscarlo
activamente por otro lado como bien
comentábamos él asumió la dirección de
al qaeda cuando eeuu mató a bin laden
también en 2011 sin embargo fue en ese
momento cuando empieza la división de la
organización and terrorista y empieza un
poco a perder notabilidad por decirlo de
algún modo a nivel internacional y
mientras a bin laden se le atribuye un
cierto carisma a él algunos ex
compañeros de la organización lo
describen como alguien controlador y
bastante arrogante se también a supone
que las torturas que recibió mientras
estuvo tres años en prisión en egipcio
en egipto perdón donde se le detuvo por
actividades relacionadas con el grupo
que él mismo creó yihad egipcia que
luego se integró dentro de la red de al
qaeda y digamos que se radicalizó un
poco y se volvió una persona más
violenta según dicen a fuentes conocidas
como lo señala él como lo reseña mejor
dicho el 'washington post' rosa pues el
washington post dice algunas cosas
también que encontramos en al yazira por
ejemplo que él cuando salió de la
prisión en egipto fue a pakistán a
trabajar para la medialuna roja y
atendiendo a muyahidines que luchaban
combatían contra el ejército soviético
en afganistán y ahí precisamente conoció
a bin laden no y entró a formar parte
digamos de lo que sería la red de al
qaeda y el washington post hemos querido
señalar un párrafo en que dice los
estadounidenses lo conocían como el
número dos de al qaeda el adjunto de
osama bin laden pero en realidad fueron
su cerebro y sus manos empapadas de
sangre las de al zawahiri las que
guiaron el movimiento terrorista más
notable del mundo bien y también en
washington post destaca lo que
comentábamos que para by the end el
presidente estadounidense ha sido un
orgullo
pues haber matado a este terrorista sin
embargo como decíamos esto plantea
algunas cuestiones sobre la presencia de
eeuu en afganistán cambiamos de tema lo
que estábamos avanzando vamos a
australia en sydney morning herald y la
bbc que informaron sobre la
reivindicación que hizo una senadora del
partido verde durante su juramento el
cargo rosa exactamente y es que como
bien decías al principio de este
programa calificó a la reina isabel
segunda que recordemos es jefa del
estado de australia así como de otros
países más allá del reino unido- la
calificó de colonizadora y es que quien
nada digamos pronunció este calificativo
fue la senadora por el estado de
victoria del partido de los verdes lidia
thorpe que pertenece al pueblo aborigen
bund y formará precisamente el sydney
morning herald e introduce la cuestionan
del siguiente modo el parlamento
australiano está lidiando con algunas
preguntas difíciles sobre la historia y
las tradiciones de australia lo que
podría venir a ser sobre la monarquía y
el racismo o la colonización del país
pero nadie esperaba debatir sobre si la
reina fue una colonizadora en lo que
haber sido un procedimiento rutinario
finalmente la obligan digamos la
presidenta de la cámara a
digamos y claroscuros actualmente a
recitar el juramento tal y como está
escrito pero ya lo acaba haciendo con un
cierto sarcasmo sin embargo vamos a ver
este momento digamos que ha dado un poco
la vuelta al mundo
señor azul por favor recite la
afirmación de salida en la carta que se
le entregó
yo soberana lidiador solemnemente y
sinceramente afirmo y declaró que seré
fiel importar y lealtad
a la cornisa dura su majestad la reina
isabel segundo
senador azul
shanghai dubai kuwait
senador azul se le pide que recite el
juramento tal y como está impreso en la
carta así que por favor repite la
oración
bueno ahí ya lo vieron rosa como siempre
muchísimas gracias nos vemos mañana con
más revista de prensa saludamos a
nuestro primer invitado al día